let's just dive right in rip the
band-aid off i know you've got a ton of
thoughts on maximalism uh some good some
bad when you think about bitcoin
maximalism uh how do you evaluate what
parts of it are good and what parts of
it are maybe not so good or need to be
changed or improved
right
so let's let's start with the good i
mean i think that the you know some a
lot of people and myself included have
this idea that
um that that it's it's a good idea to
have most of your portfolio
in bitcoin um maybe all of it some
people are like you know i'm just gonna
have i'm only gonna own bitcoin and i
think
that could be reasonable i'm not trying
to to change people's minds about that
if if that's what someone wants to do i
mean good for them
um they'll probably do well i don't
think they'll regret it in my opinion um
however
and and and also you know like
we need we need to have like a very
strong foundation of people who um
you know who refuse to do things like
change the bitcoin monetary supply right
in the end the reason that bitcoin is as
stable and predictable as it is is
because everyone who's uh part of the
bitcoin network knows that there will
only ever be 21 million uh coins created
and they will never agree to any change
to that policy and that's why bitcoin is
so stable and predictable unlike all the
other cryptocurrencies um so we need
that kind of
fierce and stable base of supporters and
that's great
um however there's also like this
subculture
of of maximalism
that that seems to believe that you know
you just need to if anyone else is
interested in anything else that's not
bitcoin then they are a scammer and they
need to be told there's camera they're
scamming people and maybe they're stupid
too and they're just evil and immoral
and that that that subculture i believe
is pretty small but it's also very loud
it gets a lot of attention
and
lately i've been saying you know i'm
talking to a lot of the people who only
got risk interested in bitcoin last year
right
um there are so many so many of those
and
when they hear the word bitcoiner it
seems like a lot of them
kind of identify bitcoiners with the
small subculture of very toxic people
who just call everything a scam
and that kind of you know it kind of
repels them kind of makes them
think that maybe they shouldn't look at
bitcoin right now because it's just the
thing is you know people people uh who
look at making any investment like
crypto or any other form of investment
uh you need to understand their
motivation you need to understand why
they want to do this
and it seems like
the toxic maximalists just don't
understand them they don't understand
the motivation of this new crowd and
because they don't understand them it's
gonna be very hard for them to
uh evangelize bitcoin to this new crowd
um just because they're not understood i
think a lot of a lot of uh
a lot of people in this small subculture
of bitcoin maximalists of toxic bitcoin
mexicans they're like saying well i
don't need to look into what's going on
in nfts i don't need to look into what's
going on in d5 i don't need to look into
what's going on in all of those things
um because they're scams
but because they're
because they're not looking at them they
have no idea how to approach this new
crowd this huge huge new crowd of people
who might be interested in bitcoin
um so when you think about it that's a
mistake let's take nfts or d5 as uh as
an example right because i agree with
you that there's uh an overuse of the
word scam right or scammer everyone used
it as that word and somehow it's been um
you know kind of morphed into the use in
uh in the terms of i don't agree with
that or i don't think that's gonna work
and they yell and scream scam and that's
probably uh a little bit of like the boy
who cries wolf you it loses the uh
veracity of the word when you just use
it for everything even things that
aren't necessarily a scam like it's
important to call out scams and so let's
wait till there's actually scams and
then call those out
um but when you look at the nfts or d5
to me
is it that people are against those
ideas or are they against them being
built on other blockchains and and some
of these questions i actually don't have
answers to right because you can't label
an entire group of people with a broad
brush but nfts is probably a good
example where nft is built on top of
another platform uh there's definitely a
subset of the bitcoin community that
will yell and scream scam all day long
but if nfts were built on top of bitcoin
would they also think they're scams or
is it just that they're not built on
bitcoin do you have a sense for
how people would look at like nfts built
on top of bitcoin or d5 on top of
bitcoin
right so that's uh
that's a great question and it's i think
you know i think people there's a very
large variety of opinions people are not
sure
some people will say nfts are for sure
scams because it's a type of asset that
is in bitcoin and any asset that is in
bitcoin is a scam uh i i find that
laughable but but that's what some
people believe
uh other people yeah they just say yeah
nfts could be interesting but you know
ethereum is a scam so if a theory is a
scam we can't use nfcs on ethereum we
should use nfts on bitcoin my
personal view is you know as an as an
engineer i learned fairly early in my
career that that
the opinions you have on the technical
side of things as an engineer don't
matter as much for the end consumer
if you know if someone the end consumers
don't care about the platform that they
use if they want to buy an nft for
whatever reason they probably don't care
as much about which platform they're on
and what the technical stability of that
platform is
they just they just want to buy nfts so
i would assume especially as nfts
assuming that this market grows
then as it grows i would assume that
people will care
less and less about what platform the
nfts
actually use and it would probably be a
mix because just because people won't
care
um you know i can i can imagine like nfc
marketplaces that support multiple
platforms at once and people will not
even know which one they're using for
which particular nfd i can i can
definitely
see that so i think that that wouldn't
matter as much in the end
right now
yeah people are like yeah
the ethereum is a scam so we need to do
one of these on bitcoin and that's okay
and maybe you know maybe that works
better i i really don't know i'm more
interested in the
asset class itself like you look at nfts
is this going to be a big thing are
people going to want to own them long
term i think that's an interesting
question i don't know the answer
but i'm interested in it in that you
know landscape and not so much about
what it's built on i think that's not as
interesting i don't really care
is it fair to say that um if you went
back to you know the 90s and maybe even
into the early 2000s there was a bunch
of debate around various protocols or or
where things were going to get built on
the internet internet intranet all that
type of stuff but today people just know
they go to google they type in something
and the answer comes up they literally
couldn't even tell you what the
technical stack is they couldn't tell
you what most of the supporting
technologies are and your vision of the
future it sounds like is more in that
realm where it's the end applications
are what end up actually being uh
important and what people care about
more so than was it built on top of any
single blockchain um other than uh it
sounds like bitcoin which you believe
has to be decentralized on on the
bitcoin blockchain but other than that
everything else it's kind of it almost
doesn't matter where it's built you know
10 years from now
yeah yeah that's pretty much how i feel
about it you know people um used to
argue about what will be the language of
server applications will be php or
python and which database will people
use will be sql or or mongodb there were
all those silly debates but in the end
when when you know when you download
tech talk to your phone
you don't even know and you don't even
care no one cares you just want it to
work so
so i assume that the same will happen
with with all of these assets now for
bitcoin specifically bitcoins um you
know bitcoin's main feature is that it's
immutable and to reach that level of
immutability and stability and
survivability like we know about bitcoin
that it's going to be around
you know probably for centuries to come
if not much more than that
so to reach that level of of stability
and security you do need a very specific
set of of technology that is very stable
behind it like i don't think you could
build bitcoin on top of ethereum or
solana or whatever
um
so bitcoin needs that but nfts don't you
know it's pictures of
of apes and dogs like it doesn't matter
really it's not that important the
reason that people collect them is not
for their superior technology or their
superior reliability that's not that's
not an issue
so i don't think people will care
yeah i tend to agree with you that uh
there's very few
use cases where decentralization is
essential or important uh money is
definitely one of them especially money
that is not created or kind of governed
by
um a uh a nation state and so it makes a
lot of sense why bitcoin would have that
decentralized uh blockchain
what's up guys bang bang thanks so much
for watching the best business show
today if we're gonna be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you 10 in bitcoin for free it's that
simple head on over to sofi.com to get
started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]